can you guys believe we finally
got the announcement super mario 3d
all-stars and it's coming in just a few
short weeks it's me
mario
but which one do you play first that's
what we're going to talk about in
today's video as well as
my story with all three of these titles
people of the internet's retro-racking
tour here and if we're meeting for the
first time i'm just a dad who loves
games and the stories they tell we post
videos two times a week here on youtube
and today it's
all about super mario 3d all-stars the
title just
announced by nintendo we've known it was
coming
for a while guys and finally nintendo
unveiled it and showed us everything
that we're going to be getting
in this mario compilation there's all
sorts of mario news to talk about but
today we're going to focus
on super mario 3d all-stars a title that
will come out for the nintendo switch
now if you haven't heard there's a bit
of an interesting quirk about the
release for this nintendo is actually
doing a limited release both digitally
and physically that means if you want a
copy
make sure you pre-order because this
thing is going to be hard to get
and once it's gone don't count on
nintendo to ever bring it back it's
really kind of strange of nintendo
anyway to have this whole mentality of
actually
taking down a digital game i think
that's that's very strange and it's also
part of my fear of the all digital
gaming future that we are inevitably
heading toward but that's a story for
another day it will contain
three super mario games on there first
up super mario 64 the 3d platformer that
started it all
super mario 64 released in 1996
alongside the launch of the nintendo 64.
it was the first mario game ever with 3d
gameplay famed nintendo designer
and creator of mario shigeru miyamoto
served as the producer and director for
the title
mario 64 is a landmark game with many of
its design elements and innovations
still playing a role in games today
mario's jump to 3d also brought the
analog stick to home consoles for the
first time
and no i'm not counting the atari 5200
the game relied on the n64's lone analog
stick to move mario around his 3d
environments
it's regarded by many as one of the best
games of all time
critics and fans alike adored the title
it was the first game ever to receive a
perfect score from edge magazine
and went on to sell more than 13 million
copies
second super mario sunshine
[Music]
super mario sunshine launched in 2002 on
the nintendo gamecube
one of my personal favorite systems of
all time surprisingly super mario
sunshine was actually just the second
mario 3d platformer in the series which
means
six years pass between the launch of 64
and sunshine
as you can imagine with the success of
mario 64 expectations were sky hot
the game was certainly well received for
the most part but few consider it close
to the caliber of mario 64.
the game did sell 6 million copies far
less than mario 64 but this was largely
due to the poor sales of the gamecube
thanks to rival consoles like
the ps2 and xbox all things considered
the title still
sold very well sunshine added a new
twist to the series thanks to mario's
robotic backpack
not only did flood help mario traverse
through the world it also helped him
clean away the goop taking over the
island
and finally super mario galaxy the
glorious epic amazing
mario title for the nintendo wii
[Music]
super mario galaxy the third 3d mario
platformer launched in 2007 for
nintendo's mega hit system
the nintendo wii most consider galaxy to
be even more innovative than sunshine
considering how levels throughout the
game are made up entirely of galaxies
filled with small planets and worlds
gravity of course plays a huge role in
the overall experience making for some
very unique gameplay moments
super mario galaxy sold just shy of 13
million copies on the nintendo wii and
is adored by critics and fans to this
day
it's actually the highest rated game of
all time on game rankings and holds a
score of 97
on metacritic so sure it may seem like a
cop-out answer
but if you're a fan of mario at all you
absolutely need to play
all three of these titles i have played
all
three of these games so let me tell you
which one you should be playing first
okay first of all easy answer if you've
never played any of the three
go with that one first i don't care
which one it is mario 64
mario sunshine or super mario galaxy if
you haven't played one of these titles
before
that is absolutely the one that you
should start with because they are
all three top-notch titles now let's say
you've played all
three or maybe you haven't played any of
them then that's when the decision gets
to be
a little bit difficult i suppose one way
of looking at it is we could play in
order of release starting with super
mario 64
then working up to super mario sunshine
and then going up to super
mario galaxy after that by the way kind
of a bummer the galaxy 2's not included
but hey
we can't really complain too much can't
wait i mean this is amazing package here
but
galaxy 2 man it's so awesome so if
i had to rank these honestly i think i
would give the top spot
to super mario galaxy now i bought a
nintendo wii
on launch day i will never forget
my girlfriend she's now my wife my
girlfriend at the time was at my house
with my with me and my family and i said
honey you know there's this uh
new nintendo system coming out i didn't
pre-order no idea why i didn't pre-order
but i didn't
and so i went to a walmart at eight
o'clock in the morning
and stayed there the entire day until
midnight when the console came out my
then girlfriend
stayed at home with my family instead so
good thing she gets along with my family
but i was one of the first ones to nab a
nintendo wii
the wii was really an interesting period
for nintendo it sold
incredibly well but it appealed far more
to a casual audience than what most
people would call a hardcore gaming
audience now i don't want to say that
those games weren't fun
they were i had a blast playing wii
bowling and wii tennis actually
believe it or not i actually won a wii
sports tennis tournament at my
university
true story but when it came to those
hardcore mario and zelda and metroid
titles
they were few and far between a couple
of the gems though
were super mario galaxy and super mario
galaxy 2.
nintendo has always been so incredible
at level design and with galaxy they
really just went for it all i feel like
with super mario galaxy because for the
first time in a mario game
you could traverse all the way around
the level
and of course gravity plays a huge role
in super mario odyssey i mean galaxy
there's a lot of mario games just bear
with me okay
super mario galaxy is one of those games
where you're just smiling almost the
entire way through it the pacing is
excellent there's
constant variety you're never stuck in
one place for too long
everywhere around the corner there's
almost always something new and
different to experience
the video footage you're seeing right
now is actually from world of long plays
make sure you check those guys out they
have a
ton of footage from old games so second
best and the one that i would go to
second would be super mario 64. for the
younger ones out there in the audience
who may not actually know
the history of this super mario 64 is
really that first
game that said wow 3d platformers
not only is it possible it's possible to
make them really really good
for years we've gotten used to mario's
this flat character in a 2d space going
from side to side
and now all of a sudden we had this huge
3d world around us
to explore it was incredible i'll never
forget the first time i saw
super mario 64. i was absolutely blown
away i went to a friend's house
he'd gotten the nintendo 64 on launch
day unfortunately my parents wouldn't
let me get one but it's okay i saved up
and bought a playstation later on anyway
and played my friends in 64.
i actually can't wait to go back and
experience super mario 64
all over again because even though the
graphics even though it is absolutely
going to look dated
you will see so many of the gameplay
elements that you know today
in modern 3d platformers started all the
way back with super mario 64.
again like so many of the mario games
before it it is just fantastic in level
design
and it's an incredible experience that
you should absolutely 100 play
to be honest with you i think the most
interesting one to discuss by far is
super mario sunshine it's the one that
has the most
disagreement among video game fans in
general pretty much everyone agrees
super mario 64
is a great game pretty much everyone
agrees that super mario galaxy
is a great game but super mario sunshine
on the other hand
has some split opinions now i happen to
be in the group that really enjoys super
mario sunshine i thought it was a nice
change of pace from the traditional
experience that we'd come to know with
mario
and it was really all because the
introduction of flood mario's little
water
backpack it actually has a name remember
professor e gad from luigi's mansion
yeah he's dude who made this you know
story has never really been
all that big of a deal in mario games
anyway but i feel like i remember the
story from sunshine better than any of
the other mario games
there are certain sound effects and the
locals on isle delfino that i still
remember today how they move the sounds
they made
welcome to isle delfino
welcome to the sundrench tropical
paradise of isle delfino
we're so pleased to welcome you to our
beautiful home
so as i'm talking through this i'm
quickly realizing that to be honest you
can't really go wrong with jumping in on
any one of these games so let me know
down below which mario game are you guys
going to play first
thank you so much for watching i'll talk
to you again soon